what can I run back to there Jenna and
junior podcast this week with our
special guest Ricky I was just here and
you're seen some stuff with them - yeah
for collab this classic critics
Christmas but cut out like the best
present ever yeah put it in collab yep
it's amazing ok so much for joining us
thanks for having me yeah thank you for
being you
this podcast is brought to you by
texture calm and me on DS texture calm
and texture is the best way right now to
read magazines like your in the future
okay no more magazines laying around
your house no more getting subscriptions
and mail that you're asked to get on
your phone
get in your tablet go to texture calm
slash Jenna Julian to check it out you
get a free trial on us trust me you will
never read magazines normally again me
undies twice as soft as cotton twice as
sexy as cotton me and these is the new
hottest underwear you can get go to me
undies calm that's MEA undies calm /
Jenna Julian to get your first pair
there you go thank you answers Oh
sponsors hey you keep us going yeah but
no seriously thank you we've actually
talked about having you on the podcast
before well I'm honored thanks for
having me yeah it is being here because
we really want to hang out with you like
I know we need to hang out more we do we
just without cameras just show up just
chill uh we have a live show a chill
night yeah this is like it's like a cool
hearing myself yeah I know that's how I
feel when I talk I'm just like I like
that voice yeah I used to hate my voice
growing up I hate I still hate my voice
really quick intro what for those who
for whatever dumb reason doesn't know
who Ricky Dillon is Ricky Dillon is a
incredibly awesome YouTube personality
and also a normal musical artist um you
begun began on YouTube but you started
everything yeah and now you've branched
out in addition you're completely still
doing all your amazing videos but you're
also doing music now you're putting
quite a bit of focus there which is
really cool we'll talk about that but
ah you knock on / Ricky Dillon yeah like
everything that was so nice yeah for
those who don't know ya know and how did
you two first initially actually meet
well hold on before I could wake up
every day to that is like my alarm and
so when we put that as an MP data record
that and like I want to wake up that was
tonight anyway um you guys were eating
at friends we met yeah you put a lemon
we met it wasn't it's actually gonna be
everything no I thought you told me on
Instagram or something you were like
okay Jenna this is when we actually met
and I was like I tell the story first of
all I'm loving your lipstick stain them
very keeping it close i what what shade
is that I have a couple of lipstick from
when I fell my vibrant purple you know
my skits I do when I wear like yes oh I
have lipstick too and I have what color
is that it's like a bright purple lip
tar that it mixed with black what is the
actual name oh that's the name cuz we
all know that there's neon is lucious
why Larry oh okay probably something
along those obviously she's like yeah
it's a lip tar you wish all right there
was no schism okay so this this story
well it'd be a bit of later well we're
gonna test check check check mate
okay so my first VidCon 2012 I was a
little youtuber I had like 20,000
subscribers I was like growing still you
know so I was very anxious like meat on
my fav it was my first time ever seeing
anyone a person I was like it was all so
new okay oh my god whoa and I wasn't
like an invited guest I just came on my
own
so I wasn't invited to the parties
edition glance party they had and so me
and my friends like oh well before oh
throughout pre oats well but like all of
us we were hanging out we were like we
have to get into this party so we snuck
in through the kitchen we went like we
found this random door she waits back
went through the kitchen ran past these
like chefs they were like whoa you can't
be here get out we're like bye and we
ran through and I came in the side door
into the party it was like really easy
do you know what
no one else did it but eyes but anyway
it was like every like youtuber I've
ever watched was just having some fun
dancing around that's not on the screen
in the flesh and it was the most
overwhelming experience ever I had not
met anyone yet it was the first day of
VidCon I just arrived and I was like
what is going on like you were just
strutting around like grace was there
Smosh Epic Meal Time
Shane was sitting there I don't remember
but everyone just walking on I almost
had like a meltdown because I have just
been watching people on the screen yeah
and then it just happened in person so I
was I was that annoying fan running
around meeting everyone so I don't
remember how I hope hopefully I wasn't
that embarrassing no oh my god but
firstly there's never a berry thing
VidCon could I make you at one of the
playlist yeah first place yeah but
really quick on interject the kitchen
thing that's [ __ ] genius because
every every YouTube person who goes up
all right gets escorted through some
kitchen I know ways I'm right I
shouldn't work physic wait let me
interject to the owners of VidCon sorry
yeah they're not gonna let you in now
yeah I don't sure my bad
watches are pocket um but yeah so as you
guys were like getting crunk relaxing I
was running around getting pictures
everyone and I found you I was like wait
getting pictures of everyone with with
it I mean I was I was like classy about
it I got wasn't like yeah first Rick I
politely asked I was like hey I'm Ricky
I love your videos can we get a quick
picture and yeah that's how we met you
were super nice you were like oh my gosh
thank you like and then yeah I mean from
from about I would say ten times going
to these I would I would estimate I've
been to though that type of thing like
ten times with her mm-hmm and she 100%
goes into these parties like she does a
full day of mean greets right whatever
panels and she goes into the parties not
expecting to be like okay time to relax
and have a drink it's more like time to
like meet people again you know even if
you're a youtuber a lot of people want
to meet people yeah and so
the fun and digs honestly I love which
is amazing because you said you remember
being nice
she's you really wasn't always that way
like yeah I think my like my caption was
like how genuine you were but you're
looking back I feel bad because like the
party is a way for like a guy after a
full day of like many people most
youtubers like to wind down the party so
I've kind of feel bad like that I don't
know bad dude it's any youtuber out
there that I met that night I'm sorry
well it was very turbulent you're not
the only one doing it so yeah true it
with all those well I do it every single
year I'm like hi oh yeah I'm Janice nice
smooth yeah I do that with like several
vines it's true z-o and then to add more
to my embarrassment the next that
following playlist at a party you came
up to me yeah I was like reggae okay
reporte right I was yeah oh my god yes
you asked me for a picture a knife but I
freaked out because you asked me and
then I think I don't know I think you
heard me I was like oh my god Jenna just
asked me for a picture what do I do
I did not hear you say that oh my god I
was just so excited that's really sweet
yeah yeah that picture we took a head
like my wallet under my arm so think I'd
like a jacked by set I remember that
it went all the comments are like Jenna
if judge is like I don't know I wish I
know I look like I'm on steroids
I want that trick wait where do you put
the purse like you right are you put it
through it like flat and you're hauling
no so just like POSIX pins yeah
and I was like that and it just looks
like like yak - Jenna oh yeah yeah it's
a toothpick we should insert these pics
in the video I'll finish you guys okay
yeah yeah yeah uh either way go check it
it's still on your Instagram somewhere
oh yeah just throw away that I was
talking 2012 yeah
just like a bunch of among yeah just
have fun along though exactly
also drones also my first pusher got at
VidCon with my most liked really the guy
I had hit like my first like I think
thousand likes with that picture so hmm
pretty hit me we make a good like arm
must have been so jacked then yeah okay
so I wouldn't like that unless her own
[ __ ] pumped up yeah well I have a
question who was the person that you
were like most nervous to me like was
there someone on YouTube before you met
them that influenced you or that you
really wanted to meet that made you like
nervous I think Shane because I think he
was the first one I found because I way
back when way way back before I you had
a channel I would like look up song
solution to and I found his parodies
didn't we all right so I watched him he
was my first one I watched so I think
I've watched him the longest my first
one - yeah and like he's still killing
it and he's still like I mean we're
friends now but he still inspires me so
but even way back then I met him a bit
that first sitcom but I was so that was
the same one you met Jenna that was the
first yeah and I have that on me me and
Shane's on videos on a video my channel
and still I logged it yeah they called
you thousand twelve it's me meeting
Shane I do not have a video I would say
the same I was super nervous to me I
just seen because I knew of just the
reason we just hung out this meth week
yeah I know I saw the girls like jealous
oh streamcon right yeah and what the
book vitami enemy air jack but my first
two were chained and digesting yeah same
Anna and I also watched what the buck
and a little bit of Fred because Fred
Figglehorn we're ray william johnson and
smosh and ryan higa yes um I just seen
was like one of the only girls like dude
she was like Duggar she was like the
queen of you chill in it yeah
Boxey was in their legs
crazy [ __ ] lonely girl was in there but
like Justine you know she put me in a
spiritual place I loved if gonna be her
but the first time I'm in shame was that
a VidCon I was like same thing wasn't
invited I sort of just wet my way yeah
so I flew yeah and just shorted like
showed up I met Hannah Hart for the
first time we had been in internet
friends and yeah we like met each other
in the lobby where you get like your
name tacos like her and AH she was like
Jaya Wow we met each other in cars that
have a story to tell big finish okay and
so I was taking the elevator I just met
Michael Buckley like in the hallway he
was amazing and he said hello to me like
oh how I don't know what to do
and then I saw [ __ ] Shane Dawson
getting into the elevator and he was
doing that like super long hair like
vest thing oh that I look the best thing
the worse and he just sort of looked at
me and I was like haha eyes me uh and
here I was like hey meet you I was like
okay see you later bye and then he got
the elevator oh that's okay I got to get
somewhere I'm sweating I don't know what
to do with my hand I'm sweating I'm
sweating yeah
no picture no nothing I was like I
couldn't make a sentence wait I want to
ask you something because you were
obviously very enthusiastic about being
on YouTube and creating yeah before you
met these people in real life because
you were watching them and you were
doing your own thing
Rickie's do a lot stop-motion yes that
[ __ ] was the [ __ ] wow you thinking wow
wow she's a good stock a fan so when you
did like get the chance to both
physically see these people in real life
and talk to them and you know meet who
you could meet what did that do for like
because when you get back home after
that you know you're obviously in a
different place right what is it what is
that kind of experience like do to you
because clearly that is something you
remember really well and it obviously
impacted how you you know change your
path yeah actually me and JC caylen and
we had like a deep talk like the day
after they got it that VidCon inspired
us both like tremendously yeah
like seeing people like in person and
like people that have like
like quote like made it like they're
having a big following like see them
like on stage until they like inspired
us like work harder and that literally
is how o2l happened that night we like
set around with JC's idea he was like
what if we just like work really hard
and come together make it this big
channel like all together and just like
making everyday videos with a theme and
whatever in language it that's all Joel
came to be so because of that VidCon you
guys all kind of buckled down at the
same time ya know we all had our own
channel already yeah but um that VidCon
like gave us like that big push it's
really cool - yeah that's cool you
remember that moment you know I remember
that vividly that's like one the best
weeks of my life there are so like
there's so much energy that like when
you meet someone that you admire really
does like pump you out there like to
keep going the coolest thing about that
first ther khon was that not owning that
I meet like my favorites to watch I met
all my friends to like boats well like
jennxpenn like in person it was crazy
like I vividly remember akkyun lolly
yeah I remember we first met he was
texting me he was late to VidCon and so
I was like where are you oh my god and I
was in the lobby like meeting
I guess everyone and he showed up and we
I could be like made eye contact across
like the lobby and we're like oh my god
should be like ran through people and
like hugged it was like super like
dramatic and I met when I met jr.
jennxpenn
she like came around a corner and she
was like the tiniest thing ever she is
teeny she was like like if you're
watching the video should like this big
like I was like woah I'm gonna get
everyone in person is smaller Dukey and
I did you agree yeah everyone's like
except however Maran that [ __ ]
is tall as tall as love yeah I taken a
picture with him at every single VidCon
I've ever been to and it's like Trevor's
here Trevor's here tyr's here Trevor
like no I mean really I'm not gonna lie
there's a couple people where I feel the
other way around
I watched them in the magenta massive
and then I meet them like you know we
launched it on vine do you know jay
versace versace he's this guy who makes
vines where you only see you like right
here any other hair you like it like a
young looking fake Julian didn't believe
me I was like actually you're right
she's a talker Patrick or key no he's a
youtuber and I've watched over a year
and I but I don't install out it's not
like this and you meet him a birthday
okay he was like six five so lately I'm
tall he towered me I was like what it's
very overwhelm the cool thing is like
seeing like people in 3d and it also
kind of just like cements in your brain
that this is a real human yeah you see
them online using and you like when you
see their height or something it's like
almost a realization that they are so
much more than what you have already
seen yeah a giant ass about them and
then you meet them in person
yeah it's so cool oh my god like so much
about your life but like you don't know
me yeah it's sad it's like I've met
everyone that like it that that
experience is so fun but like I think
I've met everyone yeah well I mean have
I you've met a lot of traditionals I
have not met you and I love you've not
met everyone because there's gonna be a
channel that you see tomorrow or the
next week or the next week that you fall
in love with Ryan you you'll have to
meet them too as I have not met someone
who I love
do you know graveyard girl god oh my god
let's take a second look I love her and
I have not met her yet so I'm still have
not met her I can still hold on to that
to that moment because I haven't met her
yet dude I [ __ ] adore her she denies
her side not described her in persons I
want to I want to better yet know if you
know good oh good yeah you don't want to
know what I experienced I first figured
out graveyard girl was because I think
it was like 2012 or something like that
and she had one like a Seventeen
magazine or something contest of like
good uh she sure to watch or something
like that so they asked me to record
like a cell phone video was saying like
uh congratulations on winning this award
keep going like you're doing great so I
checked out her channel to know who I
was talking about and that name
graveyard girl is like does not leave
you remember that sure and so I had sent
her a [ __ ] video message years ago
and then started watching her [ __ ]
channel like she is so [ __ ] legit
like she legit I mean she'll do makeup
tutorials and her voiceover is the
funniest thing in the world
I have learned how to do makeup because
I've watched her for humor but I'm like
wait a minute this fax in here - and her
um the other thing really work videos
that does best thing ever
she is like so on apology an apologetic
Lea herself all the time obsesses are
wonderful I have to know a lot because
it's hard it's hard to not respect you
boy time
absolutely I think it's interesting when
you meet someone and like you get to
like hug them and shake their hand and
you get to like you like a chicken and
you feel them and you feel their shirt
and you feel the texture of their shirt
Oh mr. doc hi
you get free magazine segue where's it
whoa Ricky's - lets get the one I
decided my clients I'm sorry no no I
love it
sneaked up on these transit I love it
it's fun for me textured on land every
time is the is the future of magazines
you and your family can all share one
account you can go on different devices
and have all your magazine subscriptions
pop up right there and guess what that's
not even it offline reading for those of
you travel or go on trains or [ __ ] read
on Wi-Fi download it for offline reading
and you have it on your device yeah
don't pay that these dollars like the
flight attendant acting out the actions
right now as I described it right this
is that's what that is
yeah so you downloaded for offline
reading you have over a hundreds of
different magazine subscriptions when
you get to the airport you're like hey I
want to buy the magazine but it's like
10 bucks 15 bucks well you already paid
that for your monthly subscription all
these different ones so check out
texture coms the future of magazine
reading textured our comms last Jenna
Julianne for your first free trial and
while you're reading you need to be
comfortable okay and the underwear
you're wearing right now is not as
comfortable as Mandy so I will guarantee
that because the undies is so soft and
so wonderful and if you take off your
pants and your around your significant
other or your pet or nobody at home
you'll look sexiest [ __ ] because I mean
these is dope and they have awesome
designs and their Instagram is fire so
check out my undies for the most lint
underwear in the entire world me on
these Emmy undies calm / generally they
apparently can
with a new pair of joggers the ones that
like sit low you know those are those
are hot right they are hot oh do me on
these oh yeah it yes just tip the
iceberg
check out our sponsors me and
accomplished annejulien textured
accomplished gently thank you to our
sponsors thanks thank you for letting me
do that let's proceed that whole time I
push it a 5/10 to doing this you are
doing it I saw biggie I was like oh yeah
you're not to do that are listening to
this and not watching Ricky just talked
it is out in somebody you know it is do
you know the American Airlines video
they play I crack up every time with
this one girl what is it I don't I
scratch over here okay yeah we know this
one this one part elastic Tinch
ten seconds like ten full seconds she
holds out like the fate did the safety
card we can read like right if you're
gonna die do this she holds it out but
it may do man on the garba back on her
face is right there oh no she I don't
know if she realizes she was in frames
yeah I think she thought it was just a
cup of sugar she's like this no holding
it over this is American American
Airlines flight watch closely because
the guy ending it could he's a pathetic
honestly she was like hey she's a very
in Derby as hell and I'm yeah [ __ ] in
but she's a very pretty girl she's cute
like she looks good but she's making
this faith like she does not want to be
there I like how you mentioned I know he
mentioned the protocol card like if
you're gonna die read it but that's what
is that like moto we're crashing now for
sure sir oh that's amazing
good idea yeah next year because now
airlines are getting like hip you know
like Virgin Atlantic is a virgin virgin
with cadre oh my god Salinas way next
things like no matter what you want to
feel about that song you're singing it
your head the whole flight okay Nathan
Delta with Lena over the attached
girlfriend that was it they have a new
one that's per Lohan theny was in that
and I I'm so mad
Oh Ricky's pissed I had my phone out on
snapchat ready to record low handsome
he's part in that Delta video and they
changed it no they had a holy minute
wait
you don't know cuz they had a whole one
of the parks that I'd seen already they
had a whole internet themed you saw it
on the Internet yeah you know they had
it for I saw I saw one in person no I
saw it in person on a plane [ __ ] okay
but they recently had a flight like Mike
Italy five different versions
I guess they maybe Mike International is
different wait till you were on the
international flight yeah it was some
like lame like generic like buckle your
seat belt there's some peanuts and it
was I was like words--all Hanson II it
was it like it has to be some internet
yeah and because I wonder I want to know
really though if they still have it on
domestic flights it was great it was
like Harlem shake yeah yeah like Lelaina
once I called the Omni and Cat nyan cat
Anthony it was like it was like yeah it
was great yeah it was great which i
think is really smart because those I
mean those videos are were the epitome
of being behind people knowing I wanna
wanna watch so what the [ __ ] yeah wait
to watch the bye
well what the what was like well had to
be singing during Harlem shake he gets
up and dances oh yeah he's like voguing
it's like great so you didn't see the
entire Harlem shake part though so it
wasn't like just he was cut out if it's
like the whole shows the whole plan but
he thinks friends said he like pops up
and like dad so on the version he wasn't
in it wasn't even her Michelle yeah so
he was okay for it was probably just
different first I got yeah I want to
bring something up uh I I feel like I've
really sort of recently been you know
really kind of into and enamored with
filmmaking you know getting creative
with camerawork and audio and music and
everything and I have an outlet to do
that which I'm so happy about like the
vlogs and stuff but when I watched your
stars video stars when it came out it
was a music video that you filmed in
Iceland you were in you were nice limb
for what two weeks right yeah but a week
about okay so you blew out a week ago
sorry okay so you made this music video
with yeah like you you went all in in
terms of getting the right people and
the right equipment and the right
shot and now does it mean that's done
you went to a lab no no you went all
done like you've done this before it was
clearly not your first rodeo but one me
so when I personally watch stars
I remember watching it and that was I
feel like it was right around the time
when I was you know getting really
really kind of obsessed with being being
in a filmmaking made I really like
interesting different stuff testing
things out and when I saw the video I
was like so blown away by the fact that
like you know you you somehow cultivated
the best group of people to create that
the song is great I love the song but
the video is really what copy for stars
I mean when you had the idea for stars
like you had the song when you had the
idea for the video and you're like it's
going to happen in Iceland how did that
like come to your brain like that as a
whole idea because it really comes off
when you watch it as a full thought yeah
it's not a half a thing it goes on it's
a complete exactly so like when I first
came to you like where did it come from
and what was it like in your brain first
of all thank you
yeah that really means a lot I got
really appreciate it I think I still by
the way have the second top comment on
that video you have the person I mean it
really really means a lot like my
favorite thing the world is like [ __ ]
like genuine feedback look thank you no
absolutely um but second I have the best
director ever Andrew Valentine loved him
to death
he's done all my videos except one and
all my music videos except one and he's
so amazing every aspect about him is
incredible like we worked together so
well what was good about him is like I
guess I feel like a traditional director
like they just kind of take control and
they're like do this do that but with
him we kind of like work together he
takes my creative input and takes my
ideas together we just had to get to his
room yeah that's really exactly I
connect so well he he knows that because
I'm a youtuber doing songs I'm not just
like throwing out a song I want to be so
much involved into the video the video
process well I want to see it all the
way through yeah yeah he loves the fact
that I want to make a video so with
every even like the song I'm filming in
Paris soon like easier on that one as
well we what we do do we like meet
somewhere and we'll sit down for like
hours and just like brainstorm and come
up with like the Victor general like
idea for the song yeah and then he
usually comes up with like a basic
concept and he's he's so create it's got
a gift that I've never once been like
for sure no yeah every autonomy gives me
idea I'm like I love it was good yeah so
his idea was Iceland what happened was I
was like I have this song and it's about
like stars I want it to be like alien
space themed I want to be like on an
alien planet so that was my idea and I
was like how do we do that he I guess he
just nude Iceland I think he had been
there before and I guess someone scouted
that locating it I think he like I think
he had like wanted to film there for a
while so he knew how it looked and I
thought it's very like it looks so like
different like they like black beaches
they have like remote like wastelands
like no tree but it's like all it's all
gorgeous yeah it looks like a different
planet
it was my fake like just Mendoza me it's
insane it's mind-blowing you have to one
person but he was like let's go to
Iceland like that sounds ridiculous and
crazy but I are you down I'm like heck
yeah like I love going all out it's my
favorite in the world so he drew up the
concept and we just kind of like put our
heads together I like drew it out and we
just went and shot he went I think he
went did he go day oh yeah we went a day
early me like scope you know he went a
week early and like drove like down the
coast and like found the places we want
to film at and then I came and we just
kind of like filmed so sick
I remember watching all your vlogs
through that - oh yeah I mean yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah the [ __ ] up you already
know that though but what I appreciate
the most especially you know when I
first started watching music videos I
think it was around the time that there
was like nobody and then sort of thing
because you were training on my radio
show so I would like hat oh hi oh yes
yes
I need to sit down and watch this
because we're playing it on the show so
I need to talk about the video or I also
know you but I'm like had seen it but
I'm like paying extra attention to it
because it's on the show right and
something like reading about where you
shot it and like you know digging too
far that's what I do and what I
appreciate the most is that first of all
you're a wonderful person there's not
[ __ ] mean bone in your body
and I just appreciate that you could
easily shoot those videos here from a
soundstage notley's yeah do them quickly
you can be done with them in like a day
you know but you take the time to make
them so in action it comes off you
really does come off like that really
though like you don't have to do it and
you do it because you care about it yeah
make the people that are watching it
feel that which I really appreciate it
and one thing is like you know a person
can watch your video and watch stars and
they were not a fan of it and they were
like I don't like this music I think
this this story is weird whatever they
can still watch your video visuals he'll
find you yes what he went you're
physically on the table already man so
yeah it's a lot of work yeah yeah you
put more work in that video probably
then I put into every single potato I've
ever upload no seriously it's a lot of
[ __ ] working through an inning and I
just I appreciate and even it even just
for you also getting the right people
behind it like it's yeah you know very
large areas and resumes yeah and like
everyone here everyone you had on the
team like I mean those [ __ ] time
lapses are no [ __ ] joke like the
regular you northern light time like
those are sick like it was really great
I'm really excited for you have new
stuff come yeah so let's get to that was
great
before that I wonder what interjection
someone because well it's my living my
favorite thing to do I just before I did
like vlogs way back when a Noblet I made
like music videos to like other people
somebody was still up I love like
hearing a song like envisioning like
ideas so now that I make music the
coolest thing in the world it's just to
like bring it to like visual life I love
it
like every song I make I want to make a
video for it woody my album coming out
that's all I want to do a video for
every single song I just love bringing
it to life that that's why not that's
why I can't play by the rules you can
make a video for every Beyonce did yes
you I'm literally gonna make a visual
album it'll take more time if you're
America
if you're ever in life considering doing
something Beyonce did it right I can do
it like it you know the only difference
is she dropped it all the ones I'm gonna
spread my now but I just I love making
music yeah it's like my biggest passion
for you identify with that for you as a
person I feel like you know years from
now you can look back on your life and
whatever happens you have these like
stunning mothers of completion and just
like really awesome [ __ ] that you
[ __ ] made like you took all the time
I mean do you ever like you ever find
yourself on set or on location like out
of the country and you're like [ __ ] this
shit's [ __ ] hard and I could like I
could walk away right now I was American
cheese I want to go all like whatever it
is like I could easily find a way to get
myself out of this and have it be
completed but you remember the fact of
the last time you did it and you saw it
to the end like that's got to be like
yeah that's gotta be the pushing factor
honestly I don't I really do love every
part of it you like travelling now in
general with with YouTube you know our
moments and I'm like I don't want to do
this then I remind myself like I'm very
grateful and lucky that this is my life
right with music videos and my music
I've never really had that moment yeah
no absolutely yeah
what speaking of music you are like
every song you could come out with I'd
say is a solid progression of getting
better
thank you remember key right so like
most of them right my name is stuff most
whatever oh yeah and so speaking of your
new stuff you have an album coming out
yet and new stuff coming out which we
got a little sneak peek oh yeah I play
them like three songs do you wanna go
sleep it was pretty great
I think you know we can say though is
you've been teasing this on Twitter
Yahoo do it with Trevor yes and
love that we just heard that like just
before this do you like it it's really
great looking fire thank you I [ __ ]
love Trevor given on the guys like
together like my brain exploded thank
you
[ __ ] me ah your album though come out um
give us your thoughts like how did it
start how did it finish yeah ok with it
like is it great I'm very happy with it
we started in March oh sure it's been a
long time I've worked really long and
hard like a weave like I've been like a
perfectionist like yeah all I go back
and forth was like this one little part
I don't like can we redo it like a back
end like I've been like that nitpicky
cuz I want it to be like my favorite
thing in the world
some of my previous songs I love them
all but this listening back this stuff
this I'm like I wish I could have redone
that here I mean which I don't regret
them I like them all but I wish I could
have like redone parts with these songs
I don't want that ever so I've been
manic made sure that I like liddie every
last thing yeah that's good so we
started in March and it was only going
to be an EP at first which is gonna be
like five songs yes but then I just kept
making more and I was at like seven or
eight and was like whoa yeah this is too
much how did you design let's do an
album so I now have eleven but it might
as of today might be twelve but just
this other producer like came to me and
was like yo I want to work with you so
it may or may was still like negotiating
it may or may not happen so it'll be at
least eleven minute mighty twelve but
definitely like like well that's a lot
so comes out of the beginning of
December or the end of November
pre-order starts the beginning of
December and it the official comes out
in a December I don't have the exact
dates yet but that's pretty exciting man
I'm so excited it's three collaborations
of announced Trevor and should my best
friend Shelby and then I have one that
haven't announced yet
[ __ ] Shelby she's the one in your
video where you do the questions but you
answer every question with a different
pose oh yeah we love that
your son is so glad we're here right oh
yeah it was like light like the body
part of that which like my wondering
when I want to clean about skin
my one go play about snapshot is how you
can't archive your stories because she
snapchat him you keep you can see they
start I know but we didn't you can take
your story as a whole I know alright
okay but she snapped out of me filming
that and it was the funniest thing I
wish we could like watch it she was
sitting there snapchatting yet in any
way so she'll be yeah we didn't do well
she she did so good like I was no I mean
I'd never heard her like full-on thing
I've heard her like sing alongs with on
the radio I was like oh you good yeah
she did really good like she killed it
to the very like nice like Taylor Swift
tone it's good like your girl girl like
yeah yeah you guys are tired since
kindergarten song is the best friend and
it's the cutest thing yeah Jenna do you
know anyone from kidding around cuz I
[ __ ] don't um no I do
absolutely no I mean nah she did really
good I was very impressed look like when
she wins the boot she was so nervous and
like me and my producer we were like
just go for it and then like she went we
shake thing and we were like wow yeah
shut up she did really good so came with
a new album yeah she'll be Trevor and
then a secret a secret person we never
still working out so I'm very excited
I'm excited too and I'm so excited that
we got to sit down with you and like
chill and talk about side you really you
you are like a I wouldn't say different
because different kind of comes off as
weird but like you're a unique
personality especially on yeah there's a
lot of people who find their way on the
internet and then they find their little
shortcut so they take moans and you've
never done that yes and I appreciate it
I really feel like Ricky is a perfect
example of someone that would be doing
this regardless of if anyone was
watching or not know what we did earlier
tonight we made that [ __ ] acapella app
video with us singing like when you
[ __ ] uploaded that look you cracked
me the [ __ ] up like [ __ ] is funny cuz
it's funny that is an example of
something that is just [ __ ] funny
move on
- thank you it's so Internet II and
[ __ ] and that's like what that
questions video is like you just you
[ __ ] do you so hard and it cracks me
the [ __ ] up that really means a lot that
you but you're very [ __ ] genuine and
sweet and you are like when you [ __ ] you
tweeted your burrito order and I was
coming out however that hilarious dude I
was like okay my Twitter feed [ __ ]
tomatoes onions rice beans of tortilla
[ __ ] whatever like chicken and then
his next tweet is oh my god I'm so sorry
that was my burrito order do what
happened when you post me so yeah
Lovelace yeah so I had like type out but
I wanted my buried mine we look this
website but I type out my burrito order
I was like I should just tweet this like
oh no Fox like some of the [ __ ] that you
tweet like with your exclamation points
but I just woke up I'm really excited
about it
six exclamation points some [ __ ] like
that like it [ __ ] makes you laugh
hilarious thank you for those who like
you and praise yeah absolutely genuine
and I'm not going to judge you but for
whatever weird reason you don't already
know about Ricky you everything Ricky
will be linked in the description so
check all that out please also thank you
to our sponsors for the podcast texture
comm for the best way to read magazines
like you're flying in a spaceship in the
future and check out our flight
attendants over here giving you the
visuals but basically texture is a way
to get magazine subscriptions right to
your device your iPhones your iPad's
your tablets go to texture calm slash
Jenna Julian and me undies for the
sexiest underwear around they are lit
they are fire literally not they're not
on that they are safe than they are
twice a soft as cotton live safe for
your body can attest like they're soft
yes or something like but they're not on
fire they're very thin on fire they're
safe Miami undies that's any undies doc
homes last Jenna Julian thank you to our
sponsors and once again seriously thank
you dude for thank you thank you you
guys are so nice
like lifted my spirits you deserve it
thanks for having me keep doing your
thing yeah we link your stuff now when
your when your ship comes out next month
we will also remind you guys about
patent equality with jail thank you for
hanging to have Mosport oh good boy I've
been almost work in art work with the
video that we made will be out and
collect I think December 2nd coming that
you're not getting really so funny I
wanted to be the first one it was funny
I want you talking like yeah we're
actually crying
so let me December 2nd look for that
video yeah kalam is so literally so
every day in December you're doing a
collaboration with another you're joking
next run like you're not even doing
every weekday day every day and you're
releasing an album and like [ __ ]
Christmas to the boss man
this my eyes I love creating yeah I know
you do yeah [ __ ] human thanks Rick's
we appreciate it to make everybody check
your stuff out and we'll see you guys
next week from the podcast